[Música]
ustedes saben que los sueños son muy
frágiles sabían eso
son frágil porque mi nación como eso
sólo tú lo tocas y que puede pasar se
revienta en verdad esos son los sueños
pero los sueños saben algo los sueños
deben trabajarse cuando se trabajen
pudiesen ser la parte más increíble del
mundo cuando hago esto la gente aplaude
[Aplausos]
increíble
pues los sueños como le dije pueden ser
algo muy frágil y muy frágil pero
también algo muy duradero muy fuerte los
sueños pero tienen que ser cultivados
saben por qué porque si no desaparecen
eso puede pasar con los sueños porque no
solamente tienen que ser cultivados
tienen que ser trabajados con raíces
firmes saben por qué para que puedan
puedan pueden crecer y afianzarse así
como esto va a increíble verdad ahora no
solamente se pueden afianzar tienen que
pensarse con esas raíces fuertes bien
bien bien enclavadas en el subconsciente
saben por qué porque entonces puede
pasar mucho
le parece están sorprendidos yo también
bueno tenemos tres pero no solamente hay
qué
crearlo en su consciencia de lo que hay
que hacer hay que tener un plan claro y
convincente para que en este momento
pueda ocurrir la magia
[Aplausos]
qué les parece me gustó la siguiente
tener confianza y saben que hay que
asumir las cosas con optimismo cuando no
sean tan buenas un emprendedor sabe que
las cosas no se logran de un día para
otro y la paciencia es el principal
aliado el principal aliado de un
emprendedor es la paciencia ellos saben
y están convencidos que las cosas
no se consigue de un día para otro y
todo es cuestión
de plazos y los plazos son largos y para
hablarles un poquito sobre lo que es
tener confianza y paciencia
yo quisiera por usted señorita quiere
trabajar y ayudarme por formar llaman a
la señorita por favor me la ayudan por
favor
dónde está mucho gusto un aplauso para
ella por favor
[Aplausos]
cómo están mira te voy a enseñar hoy a
tener confianza verdad tienes confianza
ok por favor yo quiero que le muestre al
público un pañuelo pero necesito tener
confianza de que tienes un pañuelo ahí
no tienes bueno porque es no importante
que no están limpias voy a tratar de
buscar un pañal
por favor lo tomes en señas al público
es un pañuelo normal verdad normal
puedes tomarlo con las dos puntas
yo quiero que tengas confianza que lo
vas a desaparecer vas a poder confiesen
en su verdad ok te voy a enseñar primero
para poder hacer algo tienes que
escuchar entonces fíjate voy a agarrar
este pañuelito y lo van a desaparecer lo
vas a colocar en la mano vas a hacer una
pelotita que no se vea bien chiquitita
fíjate que no ocultó nada siempre aquí
ten confianza queda desaparecer correcto
soplamos para y desaparece cuando abajo
nos aparece está aquí
bueno está aquí lo vamos a hacer ahora
vas a tomar el pañuelito vas a hacer una
pelotita que no se vea por favor bien
crítica y vas a tener confianza lo
primero que tú tienes que hacer es tener
confianza acuérdate que eso se lo vas a
transmitir a tus hijos y tu eres grande
ya verdad que su hermanita concentrate
123 abrirla por favor pero no la una
gesta el hermano habla con confianza
tiene que tener confianza volver a
cerrar
tienes que tener confianza y creo que
tener un poquito de paciencia
ok perfecto concéntrate te puedo ayudar
con unos bonitos mágicos tachán
ábrela ahora si no no no fíjate si se ha
tenido toda la confianza en su idea en
su emprendimiento
un aplauso por favor gracias
y bueno hablamos de confianza y ahora
vamos a ver qué está si hablamos de
optimismo optimismo
las cosas siempre tienen tienen que
verse un lado mejor el lado positivo
pero tampoco eso significa que uno tiene
que caer en la autoindulgencia o en la
otra parte que es la auto de motivación
si yo les muestro ustedes yo les digo
ustedes yo que yo tenía aquí para
mostrarles una prensa donde tengo unos
índices latinoamericanos en donde te
habla sobre los avances del
emprendimiento en niños y en jóvenes tú
estás pensando tendrá que ser muy
optimista este mago verdad para que
mostrar una cantidad de papeles algo
pues si soy optimista soy optimista que
en algún lugar de este periódico puede
haber algo pero tres si cree es claro
porque a ser así y si podemos ahora aquí
están los índices
fíjate que en el optimismo grupo de
lograr muchas cosas puedes revisar el
periódico si quieres revisarlo a ver si
oculta algo revísalo muy bien
que pensaba tener capacidad para actuar
y aprender
la única opción la única salida que yo
le veo al éxito al emprendimiento es
conocer lo que se hace el profesor está
hablando usted quiere que el profesor
está hablando de la biblio mulá porque
le nació un día está leyendo don quijote
hay la mula no
trabajo leyó en función de eso es algo
increíble corretja a mí porque creo que
es creativo porque de la noche a la
mañana no le hizo caso a un ser creativo
marciano que le apareció y él siguió ese
ser marciano para alejandra tengo año
las conociendo ella tiene una pureza de
alma y todo un día tu casa iba a
trabajar con el ecosistema que más y así
voy a seguir hablando de con el otro
ponente los gringos no los conozco pero
realmente no es no no es nada que que
quiere buscar hay que conocer lo que se
quiere hacer conocer vivir hizo unas
cosas del emprendedor es que prestar
atención escuchar
en recibir los consejos de la mejor
manera es la única manera de minimizar
en este caso y yo quisiera para eso
usted me ayuda de un profesor me quieres
ayudarte una tiene una semana si ven acá
por favor un aplauso para ella
[Aplausos]
un aplauso para la profesora
como esta profesora saben algo me
movieron me movieron una cantidad de
cosas que yo tenía aquí y yo la tenía
lista estas son burbujitas
que más que más tenía yo aquí oye por
ahí no han visto un billete de 100
bolívares no
me parece muy bien profesora cómo está
cómo está usted a usted a qué materia en
la universidad posgrado el posgrado en
que confíe en educación educación está
dispuesta
a aprender en el día de hoy por supuesto
si me gusta usted hoy va a aprender a su
magia usted utiliza capacidad de actuar
de aprender y como dice la lámina
quería aprender y usted va a actuar en
este momento y va a tener la capacidad
de querer y aprender a hacer magia es
muy sencillo yo tengo aquí un mazo de
cartas
y yo tengo aquí voto más o descansando
para que no nos pongamos a pelear usted
va a ser algo como esto va a ser los
primeros movimientos de magia para hacer
usted una cascada y las cartas van a
deslizarse sin problema usted tiene esa
capacidad y esas ganas de aprender sola
lo primero que tenemos que ser entonces
lo que tiene que hacer usted es tomar el
micrófono por favor
vamos a agarrar las cartas y vas a hacer
esto vas a deslizarla porque no hay
problema esto se pone nos ponemos así de
este lado y yo te ayudo tomarlas en las
cartas y deja que se enlista acuerdo que
tiene esa capacidad frente a lo que toma
las no dejándola
que bien vamos a hacer vamos a hacer la
más difícil vamos a soltar un poquito la
mano para que caigan tratar eso ahora
agarra las de arriba pues de aquí arriba
lo haces muy bien de este punto aquí no
lo sueltes nunca o que suelte esta mano
de tela claro lo que pasa que tiene un
hilo yo no iba hacer el ridículo contigo
aquí
pero yo tenía la capacidad prendida de
la profesora
[Aplausos]
muy bien
excelente bueno saben algo el por último
riesgo
qué emprendedor no asume riesgos todos
todos yo creo que el emprendedor eso
merece porque está consciente claro está
convencido
qué es lo que él siente su pasión su
objetivo principal es llegar a lo que
quiere y un emprendedor si no asume
riesgo no es emprendedor un emprendedor
él necesita estar inquieto son inquietos
de ellos necesitan mejorar siempre
detrás de es para eso yo quiero a todos
ustedes son emprendedores verdad tú eres
tú eres un emprendedor yo sé todos un
mes viejo verdad bien para que me ayudes
asumir un riesgo aquí estoy por favor un
aplauso para el señor por favor
muy bien damas y caballeros niños y
niñas perdón me equivoqué
yo sabía que yo era parte del negocio
aquí
giovanni verdad yo ni yo ni hoy hay
quien quiere llevarse estas burbujas de
aquí por favor que me está llenando todo
esto gracias
ok giovanni en el dedo
ok
yo tengo para que una guillotina tú eres
un empresario tú eres un empresario no
hablemos de eso que es dinero hablemos
de emprendedor porque hay emprendedores
que no necesariamente quieren montar un
negocio el profesor es un emprendedor y
se está hablando de dinero eso es de
ideas y eso ser emprendedor meses
comentamos nos visto en la cabeza y hay
que meterlo a los niños a los niños
tienes hermanos te quedas más o menos
y es mi la excelente idea excelente que
te hace comenzamos a hablarle de asumir
riesgos no es que se coloca encima del
balcón y agassi a mi hermanito no sino
que su más riesgo interesantes en el
colegio y todo eso tú vas a subir
conmigo un riesgo yo tengo aquí una
guillotina tú estás convencido de que
ésta que yo tina no hace nada sabes por
qué porque previamente he hablado
conmigo has escuchado mis consejos
y esta guillotina realmente no hace nada
todo es falso pero está un poquito de
sangre porque se me cayó mal el otro no
importa yo te quiero mostrar yo ni lo
que gráficamente podemos
ilustrar de alguna forma lo que es el
riesgo que asumen todos los días los
emprendedores yo tengo una guillotina
tengo una zanahoria jugó dentro plástico
hacia su mano
y yo lo que voy a hacer es contar hasta
3 1 2 3
como pueden ver funciona
[Aplausos]
desde 7 nervioso
espera de un segundo hermanito
perfecto johnnie to pensarás que brazo
voy a usar tengo poco tiempo tengo poco
tiempo no puedo pensar y terminar
contigo esto yo ni voy a usar este
elemento que tengo aquí tu pensará ya
que el mago es raro no
es un elemento técnico johnny que va a
determinar cuál de los brazos vamos a
usar con webber tienes un brazo en
excelentes condiciones baja mente y como
puedes ver este brazo yo creo que ya lo
perdimos mano
[Música]
vamos allá
pero yo ni tranquilo
todos confían en mí tú tienes confianza
en lo que yo te dije tú quieres
emprender
yo tengo casi 25 años en esto y cuando
tú decidiste hacer esto en el día de hoy
es que has visto esa experiencia mía hoy
en día después de 25 años hay una
asociación de muchos que lleva mi nombre
es con mucho orgullo
ok concéntrate concéntrate vamos a usar
el brazo izquierdo de jong y ya sabemos
por qué lo vamos a usar
ten confianza en mí él va a asumir un
riesgo como los humanos asumen todos los
emprendedores a veces no me funciona
pero esta vez creo que sí porque estamos
en un lugar casi íntimo meterlo con
cuidado
voy a colocar debajo de la mano de jon
in saben que esta zanahoria que va a
pasar le cortó la mano a johnny y cortó
las zanahorias en yo te pido por favor
yo ni que me estás todo el brazo porque
es bien difícil conseguir una prótesis
solamente un pedacito así que te te
yo quiero demostrar con esto esto es lo
que pasan a diario a los emprendedores
sí o no si no sí claro se acabaron los
insumos que hacemos no esa propaganda
que dice por ahí ok
verdad amigos voy a contar hasta 3 1 2 3
y le cortó la mano
todos los vagos usan una palabra mágica
verdad hoy voy a usar una palabra mágica
ustedes sabe cuál son las palabras
mágicas cuales usted abracadabra pues no
la mía es padre nuestro que estás en el
cielo
yo quiero que por favor veamos el brazo
de johnny como cae
perfecto yo ni confianza en mí a su vez
los riesgo voy a contar hasta 3 1 2 3
me salió mal me salió mal no la saqué
todavía yo quiero por favor que vean en
yo ni un emprendedor visionario asume
riesgo y fíjate no le pasó nada
oye
[Aplausos]
de una manera de una manera jocosa de
una manera divertida yo lo que quiero es
transmitirles ustedes
es lo que podemos lograr nosotros en
nuestras casas yo creo que podemos
lograr en nuestra desde el hogar poder
incentivar a los niños a que sueñen que
esos sueños ustedes pero ustedes que
usted han perdido sueños de acá pero yo
todavía trato
yo quiero siempre soñar yo quiero
siempre pensar en función de algo que me
haga feliz a mí a mis hijos a mi esposa
a mi familia y lo que está cambiando eso
lo que yo quiero yo lo quiero con esto
resumiendo vamos a recapitular a
recapitular lo primero es
como ayúdeme ayudarme entonces tener un
sueño imaginemos que este papel en
blanco es la mente de un niño imaginemos
por un ratito entonces
qué voy a hacer 5 dobleces el primer
dobles es
tener un sueño el segundo pero vamos a
lo que no tenía no tenía que va bien la
segunda ronda de refrigerio que sea
perfecto
entonces voy a hacer vamos a hacer un
ritual
vuelvo a decir voy a recapitular y esto
es un papel en blanco que es la mente
del niño ok y vamos a tratar de
convencerlo que lo primero que tiene que
tener es
por bien
el segundo según dobleces
no olviden el tercer sueño es
el cuarto
[Aplausos]
muy bien y el quinto
y solamente así
si pudiéramos hacer que los niños
adopten la idea de ser emprendedores
podríamos cambiar todo lo que hoy en el
mundo creo que es un problema así que
muchísimas gracias
gracias a vargas ya todos
[Aplausos]